antonio senzatella for the rockies he's
on one he's made just the one start
era 18.9 a whip of three
two out spaces clear for christian
walker
right on right senzatella and walker the
o2 is bounced the cj crone knocks down
the
short hop and waits for walker tags him
and in eight pitches antonio senzatella
gets out of the first no score as the
rockies come to back madison bumgarner
such a big part of the giants over the
years second year now with the
diamondbacks he pitched on opening day
and the batter is owens
chris is off to a nice start
fires and it's popped up
right side foul ground walker gives way
to
the second baseman escobar who called
him off and the ball dropped between
them
fortunately for the diamondbacks foul
but the rockies chris owings will get
another chance
2-2
line drive right center field base hit
hampson will cruise home that ball gets
by martay owings thinking three did not
make a good cut around second base the
throw to third is not in time
rbi triple for chris owings
mcmahon quite a night last night
three homers plus a double
against
bumgarner in his career he's over eight
with three strikeouts
does have her unban it in
ryan mcmahon
left-handed hitter
first one to him is lifted
behind
shortstop backing out as rojas and he
makes the catch that was a heck of a
pitching performance right there by
bumgarner getting story and crowned on
strikeouts getting mcmahon on a pop-up
so in this one-nothing rockies lead
tying run in scoring position for tim
locastro
crone playing well off that first base
line swung on and now a sharp one hopper
to krone he's going to third and they've
got the runner hung up fuentes running
him back and they tag kelly out
good job by cj crone took that ground
ball off one big hop and then
saw kelly trying to sneak over to third
so chris owings
will face bumgarner an rbi triple to
right center his first time
pitch from the left-hander and this
one's laced down the left field line for
a base hit moving over to field at
peralta near the warning track owings
around first and he will get into second
with a head first eye
peralta was
way back there
when he fielded the ball and owings has
another extra base hit
now with two outs of under a third as
cronus struck out his first time up
this ball is hit well to right field and
le castro can't make the catch owings
walks home and krone has himself an rbi
double two to nothing colorado
so josh fuentes at the plate with two
outs and crone at second mcmahon over at
first a run in
next pitch swung on and aligned to left
field for a base hit
cj crone around third as peralta dropped
the ball krone scores rbi single for
fuentes and it's three nothing rockies
i'll go as an rbi hit for funnies and
now diaz at the plate he swings hits it
down to short ross has got it and throws
it first for the out
and that'll retire the side but the
rockies get a pair they'll leave a
couple runners at the corners and two
down here in the fourth with the rockies
up three nothing
and here's
eduardo escobar escobar
fighting it at the plate to open up
20-21 swings and rolls it to the right
side into the shift mcmahon throws onto
first and no damage done
garrett hampson has hit the ball hard a
couple of times
dazza at second with the rockies up
three nothing and one down in the fourth
and this is going to drop a base hit daz
around third he'll come home four
nothing colorado
hampson
owings getting it done at the top of the
rockies lineup on a wednesday night
here's owings who's already two for two
of the ball game
owings back in from the right 3-2 pitch
is hammered to right center field martay
into the alley he's not going to get it
the ball one hops the wall hampton
cruises around third he will score
another rbi base hit an extra base hit
for chris owings rocky's lead five to
nothing on owings double
still only one out and here's trevor
story
pitch number 80 in the ball game on the
way
and story hits it deep the other way la
castro near the wall
he's got it
owings will tag go back to second and
head to third
two down in the fourth so now ryan
mcmahon a pop to short
and a walk over one tonight
over the plate mcmahon popped it up
cabrera and rojas as drubal's got it
and that will retire the side seven go
to the plate rockies get a pair kelly
has one of the
three hits off
senzatella a
double
but then on a
sharp ground ball hit to cj cronin at
first they got kelly
caught up between second and third and
he was
tagged out line drive to right owings
coming on dives in
hell down to the ball
has a little bit of that justin turner
v-neck uniform look going on tonight
that's become a little trendy around the
league
sends it to already this would be his
71st pitch of the ballgame and it's on
the way
swung on grounded down to third
backhanded to throw a cross in time nice
play down there at third baseball for
one is
marty's down yeah he's down at first
base and he
flipped his helmet
wide on the ground he's grabbing his
right hamstring as he was going down the
line he's had hamstring issues before
here's trevor story
here's the uh one-two pitch
from smith right down the middle strike
three
story's over four tonight but the
rockies have not needed his bet steven
boat is gonna be the pinch hitter here
he's a left-handed batter senzatella's
first pitch skips away and throw back to
third and they got him
elias diaz caught la castro in no man's
land
and now helyard at the plate
struck out swinging two on the six
two one two out
and he'll rip it down the right field
line that's headed for the corner that's
going to score a pair diaz home hanson
home hilliard digging for third a stand
up two run triple
seven nothing rockies
trevor story now and trev
over ford tonight
and they just called a bawk on s'morezak
bill welke the third base umpire
and hilliard comes home to make it eight
to nothing zero zero
is the count
one story lifts one out to la castro in
center long run for tim and he chases it
down
and now escobar
o2 pitch reach four hit the left field
das is right there shutout time for the
rockies
antonio senzutella and jordan sheffield
combine on a five-hitter